[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Isaac is
up next in Columbus Ohio Isaac how can
we help hi so I have a question so
little backstory here so my my wife and
I just got married two weeks ago
today very exciting oh yes thank you so
um we we have a little bit of debt
between ourselves um she had to get a
car about a year ago um that with her
trade in and everything that was about
8,000 um and then I think her car right
now before interest is uh 18,000 my car
is a little older um my car pay payment
will be eight about
8500 um to pay off um not including the
interest so got about two more years on
that um expected um and then couple
thousand in credit card debts aside from
that we're we don't have any other debts
no student loans we don't have a
mortgage yet we're wanting to buy house
um and that's our that's our largest
goal we want to be established in our
first home before we start having
children um we live in a currently live
in a one-bedroom apartment and it's kind
of you know we're kind of busting out of
the walls we're not minimalists by any
means but um okay hold on a second hold
on a second yes I want to set some
expectations for you my young friend uh
it's just you and the wife there's no
way you're busting out unless it's a
cardboard box you're not bus out of it I
you know what I mean do you have like
seven cats or anything weird no we
actually don't have any pets because our
uh uh apartment has a crazy $400 pet
deposit okay good you just have too much
crap you have to get rid of your crap to
go to Goodwill we do we we are
collectors for sure well then okay but
here's the point the reason I I jumped
in here I want to get you back on Pace
but this is the kind of stuff that
pushes you to make bad financial
decisions on a house you think it's just
you and your wife get rid of all of her
stuff stuff to animals or something
whatever's going on yeah what are you
collecting I don't understand how you
guys are busting out of a one-bedroom
apartment well it's it's actually kind
of funny so we we we like uh geology and
stuff like that and we like artifacts
like uh just like crystals and like
arroe heads and just natural stuff like
that so we've got shelves of it but uh
we're trying to we're trying to downsize
we give stuff away to people who like
the similar stuff we give it away as
gift so we can kind of like maintain a
healthy amount without hoarding um yeah
I was going to say what's a healthy
amount of arrowheads I mean how many
Arrowhead can one person have we got
slow with the rock collection cuz we got
a pile of debt to clean up now's not the
time to be buying rocks sure yeah no no
we're not really doing that what mainly
just going out on uh going on trails and
uh u in rivers and stuff stuff that we
find that's tell that's good well but
I'm going to tell you to stop collecting
rocks and arrowheads and start
working
that's the thing I I asked so for my job
I'm a home health aid and I I do I like
live in the position so three days a
week I'm not home and my base hours is
72 hours a week oh okay I don't know how
you have time to find arrowheads with
that schedule yeah you're not in the
apartment long enough to hate it
downtime yeah what do you make we we're
barely there um my wife uh is in the
transitional period of her new job so
she just uh got hired she starts the
23rd of this month awesome um she's yeah
so she's going to be making uh take-home
Pro estimated about $7 800 a week um I
do about N9 to to 11 depending on
overtime okay so what would be your
monthly take-home pay between the two of
you starting in a few weeks between the
two of us it will be expected to be
around 6 to 6,300 awesome that's great
news so then the question becomes how
quickly can we can we pay off these cars
and the CR credit cards making 6,300 if
we're doing nothing but focused on
paying off debt right and that's and
that's actually how we got married so
quickly we we didn't want to pay we
didn't want to finance anything uh we
spent the past year maybe 15 months
maybe just absolutely saving everything
we could paying things as we go along um
just being absolutely crazy with with
saving because we didn't want to put
anything on the credit card um in fact
because of how crazy we did it we I wish
we had had more savings by the time it
was done but do you have any right now
because yes we have we have about $2,300
in C um 13 in cash and about 1100 in uh
our savings account okay you have your
baby step one starter emergency fund the
rest of this money needs to go towards
paying off this debt do the debt
snowball smallest to largest get on a
budget we're not doing anything except
paying off this debt no rock collecting
no Arrowhead collecting
nothing man bust it you got
this good stuff thank you
George more coming up right after this
this is the ramsy show